direction l'espagne après un mois et
demi de fermeture les discothèques et
autres établissements nocturnes de
catalogue peuvent à nouveau accueillir
leurs clients sans aucune limite
d'affluence les restrictions horaires
horaires à partir d'aujourd'hui une
bonne nouvelle pour les professionnels
du secteur à clémentine laurent
c'est un grand ouf de soulagement que
pousse le monde de la nuit les
discothèques catalan peuvent rouvrir et
ce sans jeu d'occupation cela fait plus
de deux ans qu'elle alterne entre les
ouvertures et fermetures ici mais là les
conditions semblent réunies pour que la
fête reprennent la catalogne au sort peu
à peu de la sixième vague d'incidents ce
culmine encore à plus de 3000 cas pour
100000 habitants en seulement deux
semaines ce qui peut sembler beaucoup
mais c'est presque moitié moins qu'à la
mi-janvier d'un autre côté presque 8
catalan sur dix ont reçu deux doses de
vaccin et la pression hospitalière elle
diminue toutes ces conditions rassure
donc le gouvernement catalan qui a
décidé de rouvrir les boîtes de nuit
plus d'un mois et demi après leur
fermeture pour les syndicats des
discothèques de catalogne c'est donc un
véritable soulagement et nous sommes
joyeux non content ça a été très dur 600
jours alors nous souhaitons que
finalement c'est la dernière fois que
nous avons ré ouvrir alors très joyeux
tout ça c'est la première fois que nous
que nous ferons notre activité dans
cette année alors pour nous c'est très
important parce que les équipes sans se
sont récupérées les gens sont joyeux
tout le monde est content parce que nous
avons nous avions la nécessité de
tourner à travailler parce que ça
c'était très dur très dur
psychologiquement et économiquement de
manière générale les restrictions sont
presque tombé à 0 en catalogne plus de
jeu d'occupation plus de limites pour
rassemblements sociaux plus de passes à
lithaire ou encore plus de couvre feu
tout ce qu'il faut respecter c'est le
port du masque à l'intérieur et la
distanciation sociale la catalogne
retrouve donc son ambiance festive